o dia todos vocês é com uma imensa
emoção e uma grande ansiedade que eu tô
aqui hoje a não sou palestrante
acostumada a toda essa essa pompa mas
vou fazer o meu melhor onde divide com
vocês hoje aqui as experiências que eu
vivo em sala de aula todos os dias com
meus alunos
eu sou supervisor e do pib da matemática
da unisinos e o trabalho na escola joão
goulart que fica localizada em são
leopoldo
e eu sou professora da rede municipal de
são leopoldo há 14 anos
eu trabalho na escola joão goulart a 10
fui vice diretora dessa escola por seis
anos e atualmente de 2011 2012 e 2013
eu atuo na no projeto de aceleração de
aprendizagem da qual a gente nome ou se
o projeto em 2011 de projetos seguindo
em frente
sou professora formada de matemática na
unisinos e pós graduada em gestão
escolar pela ufrgs
a escola da qual estou falando para
vocês que fiquem são leopoldo rs joão
goulart ela fica localizada na vila brás
em são leopoldo
nós temos em torno de 1.400 alunos
distribuídos nos turnos manhã tarde e
noite à noite a iju essa vila é uma vila
bastante carente que nós temos muitos
problemas sociais
lá na nossa escola na redondeza na
comunidade muitas vulnerabilidades e
duas delas eu vou destacar pra vocês que
a violência ea uso de drogas na nossa
escola
então o projeto seguir em frente e ele
veio pra resgatar os alunos que inúmeros
anos estavam em repetência escolar em
evasão e tinham muito o programa de
indisciplina
nós conseguimos fazer duas turmas fomos
convidados pelo diretor da escola
assumir esse desafio que eu digo pra
vocês que é o desafio do tamanho da
matemática porque a matemática dentro da
escola é um bicho de sete cabeças então
você imagina trabalhar com turmas onde
os alunos têm um fracasso escolar imenso
na história de vida deles mas a gente
conseguiu a gente resgatou a gente teve
bastante êxito tanto que estamos no
terceiro ano
desse trabalho lá na escola bom eu tenho
parceria do pibid que entrou em 2012
lá na escola comigo a partir de maio de
2012 que foi simplesmente fantástico que
aí que veio abrilhantar ainda mais o meu
trabalho eu considero que com a chegada
do pibid que abrilhantou ainda mais o
meu trabalho
essa galera que está estudando
matemática na unisinos e veio
compartilhar comigo a docência dentro da
escola fez muita diferença eles vem
cheio de gás eles vem cheio de idéias
eles vêm tentando unir a teoria da
universidade com a prática do dia a dia
então realmente juntando isso com o
projeto siga em frente que é o resgate
da autoestima que é o resgate da
cidadania que é o aprender significativo
junto com o pibid que tem todo esse
leque de oportunidades que nos traz
nossa a gente uniu o útil ao agradável e
tem feito bons trabalhos na escola
o foco principal do projeto da
matemática dentro do pibid é incentivar
a leitura e escrita nessa área com
vistas ao aprimoramento da competência
em resolução de problemas
os nossos alunos eles não gostam nem de
ouvir a fase ouvir a palavra problemas
mas diante das formas como a gente tem
utilizado dentro da escola e isso vem
aos pouquinhos dando resultados e
mudando dentro do do projeto
nós trabalhamos em parceria então o
projeto seguir em frente ele junto com o
pib
d a gente organizou práticas
estimulantes que eu considero
estimulante dentro da nossa escola e
onde está aquele 5 pra falar pra vocês
hoje que o roteiro de leitura e escrita
dentro da matemática o mural da
matemática o uso das tecnologias como um
exemplo seus vídeos educativos os jogos
didácticos de raciocínio lógico e os
projetos interdisciplinares que a gente
passa por temática na nossa escola é bom
os roteiros de leitura escrita funciona
da seguinte maneira me reúno com os
bolsistas a gente planeja as nossas
aulas e dentro disso a gente procura
adequar textos jornalísticos ou textos
literários que tenham a ver com o
conteúdo que vai ser abordado
então a gente que a gente faz a gente
procura trazer toda a o dia a dia o
cotidiano do que está acontecendo no
país na cidade na vila na escola junto
com a matemática a gente adequa o texto
jornalístico para usar dentro da
matemática então a gente faz vários
questionamentos de cunho pessoal de
cunho interpretativo e claro abordamos
sempre usando algumas questões de
matemática e chegue para fazer com que o
aluno ele leia ele desperte a
curiosidade da leitura ele tem a vontade
de conhecer né pra aprender rural da
matemática na verdade na nossa escola
ele já se tornou o cartão de postal da
nossa escola ele fica localizado bem na
entrada principal onde toda a comunidade
escolar têm acesso
então o que a gente faz a gente procura
fazer um mural que esteja de acordo com
todos ali presentes com todos que passam
por ali que visitam a nossa escola
alunos professores pais
então além de os achadinho os desafios
da matemática a gente procura colocar
notícias coisas que estão acontecendo
dentro da escola coisas que estão
acontecendo com algum aluno específico
que seja relevante chamar a atenção ou
até mesmo dentro da vila
então todo mundo dá uma paradinha para
olhar e mensalmente os bolsistas eles me
deram muito pra trocar esse moral
fazendo sempre tornar um pouco mais
atrativo e até mesmo imperativo para que
os alunos sempre busquem respostas que
irão ler mais sobre o assunto depois do
mural da matemática gente esse ano eu
vou dizer pra vocês eu fui bem amadora e
foi muito corajosa com graças aos
bolsistas que estão comigo ea gente é
tentou usar então a tecnologia dentro
das nossas aulas como que a gente fez
isso a gente distribuiu distribuiu nas
nossas turmas 12 desafios matemáticos
esses alunos foram distribuídos em
grupos ea gente propôs pra eles fazer
curtas matemáticos como assim a gente
levou eles leram conheceram
interpretaram e resolveram as questões
propostas cada grupo resolveu o céu
depois disso a gente propôs a eles que
eles encenassem aquele desafio contasse
a historinha daquele desafio então ele
se preocupar com figurino com o cenário
e um roteirinho que eles iam falar a
gente filmou isso organizou editou
colocou eles todos no auditório depois
de tudo pronto fez uma sessão de cinema
o direito à pipoca
levamos eles até lá e aí a gente vê o
seguinte a gente passou um por um dos
desafios mas da seguinte maneira passava
não todo até a resposta até a solução do
problema e sim até a parte onde
instigava e fazia todas a toda a parte
de questionamento do desafio parava
todos eles paravam daí todos os grupos
porque daí só o grupo sabia solução
daquele então todos eles foram
instigados a responder e depois a gente
passava a solução porque matemática tem
uma coisa muito boa e existem vários
caminhos para se chegar naquele
resultado então vários deles a
professora mas eu não pensei dessa forma
o problema vamos ver como é que vocês
então a gente conseguiu problematiza a
gente conseguiu conversar e isso
realmente foi o estopim para mim esse
ano valeu muito
o dia que a gente conseguiu fazer porque
realmente teve bastante destaque na
aprendizagem e eles adoraram fazer tudo
isso cabe destacar que a gente usa
tecnologia de uma forma a forma que é
mais adequado a gente usou câmera
digital porque a gente não tem internet
a gente não tem computador para todo
mundo então a gente adequa conforme a
gente consegue fazer na escola jogos
didáticos que é algo que é praticamente
todo o professor de matemática uso em
sala de aula os alunos adoram adoro
jogar principalmente porque eles gostam
da parte competitiva do jogo a partir de
ganhar
eles adoram mas a gente fala eu acho que
o jogo além disso ele estimula muito
mais porque existe todo um trabalho em
equipe feito ali
então se eles analisam junto com o grupo
porque eu errei porque eu acertei ele é
isso aqui que não deu certo tá outra
então eu faço muito trabalho muito os
bolsistas me auxiliou muito nisso porque
eles pesquisam bastante eles organizam
todo o material além de fazer esta
aplicação
eles aplicam e o supervisor no organismo
oriento eles ea gente está sempre
trabalhando junto então assim é
realmente o material de jogos enriquece
além de tornar a um pouquinho mais leve
mais lúdica e por último eu vou falar
pra vocês que eu acho que é algo que a
gente usa muito no nosso projeto a gente
consegue muito isso nós somos em quatro
professoras no projeto seguir em frente
a gente trabalha muito por projetos
interdisciplinares
o projeto interdisciplinar como eu
comecei em 2011
o nome do nosso projeto foi nós somos os
resultados das nossas escolhas
nós trabalhamos com outra temática maior
escolhida por eles que era profissões
eram alunos bem velhos já tinham a
partir de 16 anos em diante eles tinham
muita muita preocupação
o trabalho eles queriam muito saber como
é que eles poderiam trabalhar e aí eles
confundem a questão do trabalho informal
a informalidade com o trabalho a
profissão com estudar por se qualificar
então a gente aproveitou esse momento
buscou parceria do senai do senac da
directiva e trabalhamos muito em cima
disso teve resultados excelentes porque
na volta eles vêm dizer pra gente o que
eles conseguiram depois daquilo
em 2002 nós trabalhamos com perspectivas
futuras também entrou profissões mas
entrou um outro uma outra temática que a
prevenção da gravidez na adolescência
que a gente tem observado a cada ano o
índice muito alto de gravidez na
adolescência dentro da nossa escola
em 2013 o nosso projeto ainda está em
andamento nós não terminamos não
concluímos ainda e ele focou mais
diretamente na gravidez na adolescência
que é algo que estava realmente bastante
forte a gente venha vinha acompanhando e
vem a cada ano que passa e se
preocupando cada vez mais com esse
índice alto
a nossa meta esse ano era não ter
gravidez dentro das nossas salas de aula
que é aonde marchinha mas a nossa meta
foi superada por esse a gente já tem uma
grávida apesar das palestras apesar da
conversa apesar de todo o trabalho feito
em matemática ciências história
geografia educação física todos os
professores se envolveram de uma forma
super dedicada e onde a gente imaginou
que poderia trazer bastante por eu
acredito que trouxe frutos porque se dos
outros anos eram 156
esse ano a gente tem uma eu acho que a
gente conseguiu
não atingimos a meta que era zero mas
acho que a gente chega lá um dia
então eu queria dizer pra vocês que meu
recado era esse dizer que estou bastante
feliz aqui pedir desculpas pra vocês
pelo meu nervosismo mas dizer pra vocês
que eu amo o que eu faço eu adoro
trabalhar com os meus alunos que eu
acredito que todo
podem aprender e que realmente ensinar é
correr risco e ensinar é arriscado novo
e simplesmente não querer nenhum tipo de
discriminação
agradeço a todos vocês muito obrigado um
ótimo dia para todos